Hi, this is Dr. Flaum,
and this is the OMM
lab prep video for
PPOM1 lab number 29.
High velocity, low
amplitude for the lower
extremities, including
tibia, fibula,
subtalar, tarsals, and
metatarsal regions.
This is an overview
of the anatomy
that we will be
addressing today.
Again, please study
the anatomy carefully.
and be prepared to
make a diagnosis
on your partners
of these areas.
High-velocity, low
-amplitude, or HVLA,
for a trapped
navicular cuboid or
cuneiform with the
HISWIP technique.
Patient is asked to
lie prone on the table,
with the physician
standing at the side of
the table closer to
the foot of the table
and on the side of the
somatic dysfunction.
The physician flexes
the patient's hip and
knee on the side of
this function and drops
the leg on the side of
this function off the
side of the table, as
shown in the picture.
The physician uses
both hands to grasp the
patient's foot, placing the
thumbs in a V-shape over
the plantar surface of
the cuboid, navicular,
or cuneiform, whichever
it is that is in a
drop position relative
to the other metatarsals.
The physician delivers a
downward thrust through their
thumbs into the sole of the
foot at the level of the
dysfunctional cuboid
ventricular cuneiform, while
simultaneously inducing a whip
-like action at the patient's
ankle and knee, hence the
name HISTWIP technique.
The physician can introduce
a more medial thrust
for the medial tarsals
and a more lateral thrust
for the lateral tarsals,
the lateral aspect
of the foot is opened by
adducting the forefoot.
The physician reassesses
the range of motion of the
forefoot and palpates for
the dropped cuboid navicular
caniform to determine
effectiveness of treatment.
HDLA for anterior tibiotalar
dysfunction, which
is also known as an
anterior tibia on the talus.
The patient is asked
to lie supplant on the
table with the physician
standing at the foot
of the table The physician
uses their corded
hand to cup the calcaneus
anchoring in the foot
Slight traction
may be applied The
physician places
their cephalid hand on
the tibia proximal
to the ankle mortis
The physician delivers
a thrust through
their cephalid
hand on the tibia
directed straight
down toward the table.
See the white arrow.
Physician reassesses
the glide of the tibia
on the talus and the
range of motion to
determine the effect
of domestic treatment.
HVLA for posterior
tibiotal dysfunction,
also known as a posterior
tibia on a talus.
Patient is asked to lie
supply on the table with
the physician standing at
the foot of the table. The
physician wraps their
hands around the foot with
their fingers interlaced
on the dorsum of the foot.
The physician uses
pressure from their
thumbs at the ball
of the foot to
dorsiflex the foot to
the motion barrier.
The physician places
traction on the foot
while increasing
dorsiflexion of the foot.
While increasing the degree
of foot dorsiflexion,
the physician delivers
a tractional thrust.
See the white
arrow in the image.
The physician reassesses
the glide of the tibia
on the talus in the
range of motion of the
ankle determined
effectiveness of treatment.
HVLA for an anterior tibia on
the femur somatic dysfunction.
The patient is asked to
sit on the side of the
table with a small pillow
underneath the thigh
on the side of the
dysfunction as a cushion.
The physician is
seated at the side
of the table
facing the patient.
The physician places their
thumbs on the anterior
tibial plateau with the fingers
wrapping around the leg.
The physician ensures the
patient's thigh and leg
are relaxed by springing
the thigh up and down.
The physician delivers a thrust
straight down toward the floor,
traction down, while
simultaneously applying a
posterior pressure impulse with
the thumb's multidirectional
thrust through the white
arrows in the image.
The physician reassesses
anterior glide
and the range of
motion of the knee to
determine the
effectiveness of treatment.
HDLA for a posterior tibia
on femur somatic dysfunction.
Patient is asked to lie
prone with the dysfunctional
knee flexed to approximately
90 degrees if possible.
The physician is standing or
sitting at the
foot of the table.
The dorsal of the patient's
foot is placed on the
anterior medial aspect of
the physician's shoulder.
This placement will induce
plantar flexion of the
foot, taking tension off
the gastrocnemius muscle.
The physician interlaces
and wraps the fingers
around the proximal
tibia, just distal to
the popliteal region,
as shown in the picture.
Physician delivers the
thrust with both hands
towards themselves
parallel to the table,
as seen in the picture below.
Physician reassesses
posterior glide
and the range of
motion of the knee to
determine effectiveness
of treatment.
HVLA for an anterior
dysfunction of the fibular head.
Knee would be a proximal
fibular dysfunction,
short lever posterior
with inversion emphasis.
For example, a right
anterior fibular head.
The patient lies supine
with a pillow under
the dysfunctional knee
to maintain the knee
in slight flexion.
The physician's corded
hand internally rotates
the patient's ankle
to bring the proximal
fibula more anterior.
The physician places
the heel of the cephaled
hand over the anterior
surface of the proximal.
Eighth thrust is
delivered through the
fibrillar head straight
back into a table.
See the post-wet arrow.
Simultaneously, an
internal rotation
counterforce is
introduced from the ankle.
See the curved white arrow.
The physician reassesses
the range of motion,
position, and tenderness
of the fibular head
to determine effectiveness
of the treatment.
HDLA for a posterior
dysfunction of the fibular head.
The would be a proximal
fibular dysfunction.
This would be a long lever
fulcrum eversion emphasis.
For example, a left
posterior fibular head.
The physician lies prone,
I'm sorry, the patient
lies prone with the
dysfunctional knee flexed at
90 degrees. The physician
stands at the side of
the table opposite the
side of the dysfunction.
The physician places the
MCP of the cephalid index
finger behind the
dysfunctional fibular head, and
the hypothenar eminence
is angled down into the
hamstring musculature to
form a wedge behind the knee.
physician's corded hand
grasps the ankle on
the side of dysfunction
and gently flexes the
knee until the restrictive
barrier is reached.
The patient's foot
and leg are gently
externally rotated
to carry the fibular
head back against
the fulcrum formed
by the physician's
step-led hand,
white arrow below.
Physician's corded hand
controlling the patient's
foot and ankle delivers
a thrust toward the
patient's buttock in a
manner that would normally
result in further flexion
of the knee, white arrow.
However,
the wedge focal formed
by the physician
exceptional head
prevents any such motion.
The physician reassesses
the range of motion,
position, and tenderness
of the abdominal head to
determine the effectiveness
of the technique.
please review sacral
diagnosis and sacral met as
these are review materials
for this lab thank you